Look at these tunnels that
Hamas uses to get its missiles.
Hamas is this anti-Israeli
militant group down in the Gaza Strip.
It's a part of Palestine.
Gaza is sandwiched between Egypt,
the ocean and Hamas's enemy, Israel.
They're totally isolated
and blockaded from the world,
and yet they still managed
to get all of these rockets
that they shoot into Israel.
These rockets and their parts
mostly come from other countries
like Iran and Syria.
Historically,
they've made their way into the country
through this network of tunnels.
Israel's always finding these tunnels
and trying to shut them down.
But they certainly still exist.
They also do this thing
where a ship off shore will drop a floating
capsule full of weapons
and it will be picked up
by these scuba fighters.
One way or another,
they use these black market
smuggling techniques
to get these rockets into the country
and they build up a huge arsenal
and then they kind of release them
all at once,
which is what they recently
did starting this new war.
If you want to understand
what's happening in this conflict,
follow along for more.
I'm going to be covering this.